انظروا إلى هذه الصور التي تم بثها اليوم مرة أخرى
ومرارا وتكرارا من مستشفى في جنين حيث يدخلون
يتخفى مقاتلو يميم ويقومون بالقضاء عليها
ثلاثة إرهابيين موجودين هناك بالتأكيد
أنفسهم كأعضاء في الطاقم الطبي، بالطبع نحن لسنا كذلك
نرى الإزالة نفسها، نرى
كاميرات المستشفى
من المكان هناك بعض المشاكل يفعلون الأشياء
القبيحون من حيث أنهم لا يدخلون إلا المستشفى
عندما نتظاهر بأننا أعضاء في الطاقم الطبي، هناك أيضًا
لا توجد مشكلة في هذا، ولا توجد مشكلة في هذا
نحن نتظاهر بأننا ما نحتاج إلى إنفاقه
الإرهابيون في كل مكان لن يتخلوا عن النصر
علينا أن نحقق الفوز لنحصل عليه
نحن بحاجة إلى الاهتمام بهذا في القطاعات الأخرى وهذا القطاع
حلبة
أعتقد أنها ليست مهمة وهو أمر مهم للغاية
أنه منذ بداية العام أكثر مما كان عليه منذ البداية
لقد انتهت الحرب بالفعل هنا، ولا مزيد من الأغلال
كانت هناك تويا بما في ذلك الآن في G. وهي اليوم جامحة
التفاؤل بين الأطراف المشاركة في الرحلة
وبند بشأن الرد المتوقع نيابة عن حماس
المتوقع نيابة عن السنوار وصدقت في البداية
أن الجميع يفرك السنوار واليوم سبب المعلمين
التفاصيل تخبرنا أننا مشتاقون للتغييرات
وحتى التغييرات الرئيسية في الخطوط العريضة لحماس قابلة للتطبيق
سوف يجيب يشيم بالإيجاب في الخلاصة على الرغم من ذلك
الأشياء التي سمعناها في اليوم الأخير، من بين أمور أخرى، بالمناسبة
وحتى رئيس وزراء إسرائيل اليوم ضال
يقال التفاؤل حتى لو كان هناك جواب إيجابي
حماس ستحدث تغيرات كبيرة ويقولون أيضا
العبارة الرئيسية التي لا تقل أهمية هي الحاوية
قرارات صعبة للغاية سيتعين على الجمهور اتخاذها
ومن الحكومة سيكون أيضا فيما يتعلق بوقف إطلاق النار
والتي من المحتمل أن تكون مهمة ولكنها أيضًا غنية
القوات الأمنية التي أفرجت عن بن من حيث الكمية والوحدة
جابر يهدد اليوم بإسقاط الحكومة وذلك
أوريا يخبر نتنياهو في لقاء شخصي بينهما
يجلب Solberg الأشياء التي قيلت هناك نعم
لذلك تم عقد هذا الاجتماع أودي يوم الأحد
نتنياهو وبن جفير على خلفية انعقاد القمة في باريس
كما أنها تكهنت بقضايا أخرى وهناك في الغرفة
يشكل بن جفير المغلق نفس التهديد الذي يمثله أيضًا
قم بتسميته علنًا وهو يقول الاسم للرأس
ومن الواضح أن الحكومة إذا تم التوصل إلى اتفاق يتضمن
وقف
حرب